as i mentioned in my last division video
on manhunt season 3
we were left with far more questions
than answers especially when it comes to
the hunters
but there was also this mysterious new
character who was calling the shots
in regards to bad and shafer and the
btsu
although it's awesome to see the hunters
actually being featured in the story
in one way or another it's really just
led to further speculation on the origin
but as a number of you have requested
for some reason you'd actually like to
hear my ramblings on the topic
which is cool because i kind of like
making these speculation videos
even though they're often less about the
facts and more about the what-ifs
based on the sometimes very limited
amount of information that has been
presented to us within the game
plus my wife likes it because i'm
sharing my thoughts with you rather than
bugging her with the over-the-top ideas
that
really mean absolutely nothing to her
this is often a more relaxed sort of
video where i taper back the slightly
more monotone style of story narrative
and try to focus on what we've seen so
far and what it could possibly mean
basically i geek out to people as nerdy
as me when it comes to the potential
direction
the subject in question could be going
and in this case
we're talking about natalia sokolova and
the hunter that seem to be assisting her
in the black tusk
i'm not going to run through all the
previous theory and speculation around
the hunters
i may refer back to it from time to time
but i assume the majority of you
interested in this
have likely seen my earlier videos on
the topic or have read about these sort
of ideas on the forums or read it
so rather than wasting your time i'll
simply post a link to each of these
videos in the description
for now let's discuss what we saw of the
hunter in season three
leading up to each of the minor manhunt
targets he would make himself known as
we were fighting the rogue agents
but he didn't appear to be solely
targeting the division agent he was
hostile towards the enemy rogues
and their supporting factions yes we may
have been able to take him down during
the manhunts but
it was very obviously not was intended
by the writers
so disregard any of that for now the
majority of the time if the hunter was
focused on by agents he would simply
vanish in a cloud
of smoke not appearing again until the
next manhunt showed up
and then rinse and repeat unless of
course he managed to catch you by
surprise and take you down first
but let's not talk about that
this went on and on until barden
shaffer's location was finally made
known
on coney island this hunter was
targeting rikers who was scattered
around the mission
but he was also toying with the agents
until baden eventually told him to quit
playing around and finish
the job and this is where the agents
were finally able to fight
without having him disappear so a few
points that we can note from the season
just passed
it was the same hunter we were meeting
up with throughout the manhunt his mask
seemed a little different to the other
hunters we've seen so far
he was hostile to all but black tusk and
that includes baden's rogue agents
he was taking orders from baden his
voice over on the comms sounded
animal-like and almost mechanical and
natalya circle over
was aware of the hunter and even
inquired of them
after my last video on the roundup of
the season 3 manhunt
and based on the new information i was
inundated with comments and dms
on the possibilities behind the hunters
and natalya
a number of them i was actually quite
aligned with so i've gone through every
single one of them
added a few of my own and the majority
of them could be grouped
under one of the following the hunters
are contractors
or a pmc for hire they are brainwashed
or conditioned soldiers
the hunters are a product of vikram
malik
they could be black tusk or maybe
they're russian special forces
the hunters are contractors or pmc for
hire
this theory is quite widely discussed
and has a number of different variations
that conclude the hunters to be some
sort of super specialized mercenary unit
and that barton schaefer employed them
to help take out the division agents
both rogue
and non-rogue the reason he had them
attacking the rogue agents even the ones
he was trying to work with
was because he decided that they were
far too difficult and needed to be
removed from the equation
where this pmc has come from is anyone's
guess but there seems to be a strong
support for them coming from rogue or
disbanded agents that didn't join up
with kinah
or if you wanted to add speculation to
even more speculation
they are ex-us military based on their
tattoos
potentially from a unit that barden's
btsu was also involved with
they have since come together to
collaborate with re-establishing the
government
this would help to explain the tattoos
and potentially why there is only a
single hunter that was helping them
perhaps they only paid for one who knows
but the hunters have been in contact
with division agents in the past
and have already lost comrades during
these altercations assuming they were
given a brief on their role in the
mission they surely wouldn't have just
sent
a single hunter to assist regardless i'm
not overly convinced that they were
rogue
or first wave disbanded agents who chose
not to side with kina
after all they were killing other rogue
agents who had also chosen not to side
with kina
plus they are considerably stronger
also natalia very obviously has
something to do with them and she'd
already told schaefer that he had to
work with the rogues
but the main thing that doesn't sit well
with me is that if they were american
pmc
where have they been hiding up until the
point of the outbreak
even the black tusk although very
secretive was known as being a pmc
and that they had ties to the government
i can't imagine it would have been
particularly easy to cover up the use of
such a brutal soldier
and the traces of their work that they
left behind
plus their equipment how does everyone
seem to have shd tech these days
the hunters are brainwashed or
conditioned soldiers
this theory talks to the hunters around
how they are possibly brainwashed
american soldiers
or have been conditioned over time maybe
even experimented on through scientific
treatment
they've basically been engineered by a
government organization like the cia
as a new type of super soldier this
experimentation resulted in killing
machines
that are extremely loyal and obedient
but have seemingly been left without the
power of speech
potentially this was done on purpose so
if captured they would be unable to give
specifics on the mission they were
employed for
or maybe it was just a side effect of
the treatment
this line of thought is further
supported by the g philips protocol
in a particular residential location
being a cia facility in real life
and also once again the military tattoos
talking to them being us military
it's also possible that when president
ellis changed sides he gave the black
tusk the information around this
experiment
as he was the vice president when he was
contacted by the black tusk he would
have likely had access to this type of
sensitive highly confidential
information
i don't really have much to say on this
one other than the same queries i had
around the previous
like why are those loyal brainwashed
troops attacking the rogue agents that
are supposed to be working with black
dusk
but it just doesn't really feel like the
right fit based on the story so far
it feels a little bit too far out there
for the division franchise
sort of like we're verging on adding
zombies to the story
so maybe i'm a little biased on this one
because i'd really hate to see them take
the lore down that path
but um well stranger things have
happened
the hunters are a product of vikram
malik
this one certainly has some merit i'm
not sure where it originated from but it
was sent through to me by a number of
different people
vikram malik if you have no idea who
this is i'll quickly re-jog your memory
earlier on there was a side mission
called odia tech office
the division was tasked with securing
some new battery packs for the theatre
settlement
once inside the office they found a
civilian called vikram malik
he worked for odiatech and was being
held there against his will by some
hyenas
the agents rescue malik but the
batteries aren't there the place had
been completely looted
malik agrees to help the division by
locating some new battery packs
and meets them at the odea retail store
also he needed to gain access to the
computer in the store to find some files
he needed
staying in the office malik directs the
agents to the basement
while down there he triggers the alarm
gaining the attention of all hyenas
within a two block radius
malik had set them up and after escaping
the building was never seen from again
the idea is that malik working for a
global communications company
had designed a new urban warfare
technology
however we'd later find out that he's
been fired from the company
prior to the division rescuing him it's
possible that his vision for the project
was
getting more and more extreme and out of
control so adir had to let him go
from there malek contacted the black
tusk and told him of his work
with the black tusk's large financial
backing they were able to give him
everything he needed to create
what we now know as the hunter hunters
are equipped with the latest technology
from odea research
months pass and malik realizes that his
research and data are still being stored
on the idea service
and this is where the division finds him
trapped in their offices surrounded by
hyenas
he is there trying to delete any
remaining data from getting into the
hands of the enemy of his new employer
but because the idea offers computers
were out of action he would have to go
to the odia retail store
which is where the division agents came
in at the perfect time to help them
fight their way through
with most of these speculations around
the hunters and i've seen a lot
there are certain events that have
happened over time that feed into these
stories
and on the flip side also disprove them
with this one also based around a couple
of side missions
there really is nothing else that talks
to it don't get me wrong actually quite
like it especially how it gives some
more meaning behind the vikram malik
story
given that he just up and vanished but
it's almost like we're talking about
another smaller character whose story
didn't really go anywhere
and we as overspeculating nerds who
enjoy the game
check our own ending and interpretation
behind it
there really just isn't that much to
back it up almost 100 speculation
and i understand how odd that sounds
given that all
ideas around the hunters it's complete
speculation at this point
i mean i hope i'm wrong it would be good
to see another character having a story
be completed or
added to the game but there are a couple
of other very small things that don't
quite sit right with me
like why would the main odir servers be
accessible by a retail store
in a previous life when i worked for
companies that would hold sensitive
information
i mean not super sensitive information
like urban warfare stuff or anything i
mean i live in new zealand after all
but there would be no way on earth this
information could possibly be accessed
by the front-facing systems
in reception for example but maybe i'm
reading into this a little too much
however how did he even know of the
black tusk there was very little
information of them out there
let's say he was aware of them how did
he know of their current operation
when even the united states last line of
defense the shd
had no idea maybe the black tusk was
given intel on his work
and it was them who first initiated
contact
like i said there would have to be a
number of pieces that came together in
order for this to work
and we really haven't been given
anything that would point in this
direction
but at the same time we haven't been
given anything to prove otherwise
so technically it's still a perfectly
valid theory
the hunters are black tusk
this would have to be the most popular
theory out there i don't really have to
explain this one so much it makes
complete sense after all we do actively
see the hunter working with the black
tusk in the manhunt
so they're obviously connected in some
way they would have also been the
perfect soldier type for hindering the
division's movement
in the beginning while still keeping the
btsu identity hidden
they could be a special unit of the
black tusk
but the question is are they black tusk
or are they simply working with them
this could explain what barton meant
earlier on before the invasion
when he told his boss that he already
had a team in mind and that they are the
baddest of the bad
ruthless cutthroats or something along
those lines
also the black tusks at one point after
revealing themselves
were given an order to back off from
taking down the division agents
if the hunters were black tusk they too
would have received the same order
which would explain why the hunters
later on in the division 2 were in a
more docile state in comparison to the
ones we met earlier on
we were the ones hunting them however
they seem somewhat distance from the
btsu
there seems to be far more to the story
than simply being a part of the btsu
like why have we not seen them earlier
in some of the more vital missions that
the division has managed to put a stop
to
sure it could be because they are more
suited to urban execution-style combat
but that wasn't exactly what we were
seeing from the hunter during the
manhunt
and why only one hunter the way barden
interacts with the hunter certainly
gives more of a feel that they're more
of a third party a hired gun
or a borrowed operative and then there
is natalia's knowledge
and questioning around the asset this
leads me to believe that there are more
to do with the next theory
the hunters are russian 100
the second most popular and probably the
longest surviving theory on the hunters
out there
the reason it's so strongly supported
today is because of the introduction of
a new name
natalia sokolova this surname is among
the 10 most common russian surnames
and although there is a small amount of
variation in the name it's quite likely
that she is in some way related to the
circle of concern
brand set or more specifically the
circle of corporation
now apparently this is common knowledge
although i certainly had no idea
but in russia it's often the case that
females of a family would have a slight
change to the surname
some of you would clearly be able to
explain this better than i and this
probably isn't the video to be talking
about it
but this has something to do with the
russian nouns having a gender associated
with them
and with feminine nouns they often end
with an ah or
sound i found it interesting
but i digress if natalya is in fact
related to the sokolov company
this would certainly explain the power
she has over barden schaefer
it's likely this large international
company has considerable financial
backing
and is among or perhaps the main
corporation behind the employment of the
black tusk
the hunters could be a unit of the
sokolov corporation
or dare i say it russian special forces
another somewhat obvious piece that has
always supported this theory
is the writings of the man himself tom
clancy
in his books it was relatively common to
find the antagonists to be russian
time and time again he will talk about
the highly trained and specialized
russian agents
sent to destabilize the us government
often they wouldn't be heard talking
instead communicating with bizarre
noises in an attempt to hide any
indication of their origin
sounds familiar right
this would also talk to the advanced
nature of the black tusk technology and
weapons
however there are a couple of points
enough people are brought up
that it's worth talking about for
example if natalia is part of the large
russian corporation
and is from russia where is the accent
to be honest it isn't too hard to
believe that she has learnt to hide the
accent
i mean this has been done countless
times over the years
plus look at actors things can be picked
up over time
and she could have been trained in this
since she was young for all we know
the hunter tattoos i talked about in an
earlier video these are very obviously
us military tattoos
so if they're a russian why would they
have them this could just be another way
of misleading and hiding their identity
or as i've said before they could simply
be a reused asset by the design team
but what about barden schaefer he is a
true patriot
and believes what he is doing is best
for the country
formerly in the military would he really
think that a russian-based corporation
would be the best thing for the united
states
well maybe he doesn't know the way
natalia talks to him
is quite vague he's perhaps in a
need-to-know situation
and this could also explain why she
talks to him with an american accent
again i still question why only one
hunter was sent in
surely they would have seen other
hunters have been taken down
but when you think about it the manhunt
was called concealed agenda
and we really weren't given much of an
idea of what baden was doing
maybe the hunter really was just being
used as a distraction along with the
rogue agents
to keep the division busy while barton
was doing whatever he was doing
i don't think baden being taken down and
captured was a part of natalia's plan
but at the same time she probably saw
him as disposable
going back to tom clancy's writings i
always laugh when this one comes up
because of always reading about how ngn
knows nothing about the way tom clancy
writes his books and that's fair to be
honest
a lot of my speculations of the many
videos have purposely aimed away from
following that path
i have in fact read quite a few of his
books and i do understand the familiar
direction his books seem to take
but as we all know tom clancy didn't
write the story of the division
it uses the tom clancy name and his
previous books inspired the form in
which the story was written
but the division in general plays out
much differently to any other tom clancy
game
which are usually more tactical and
ridiculously unforgiving
random fact tom clancy actually
co-founded redstorm entertainment
which was later acquired by ubisoft
[Music]
tom clancy died in 2013. his family now
handled the ip
behind the name and given how the
division ended up being considerably
different to previous clancy titles
it would appear that they're a little
more liberal with what can and can't be
done with the name
so i didn't see it as completely unusual
for the writers to take things in a
slightly less clancy direction
however if i'm going to be completely
honest after saying all that
the exact moment i saw the name natalia
sokolova come up within the game
i knew that this wasn't the case in my
opinion if you wanted to hear it
although you obviously don't have a
choice because this is a pre-recorded
video and i've made the decision for you
i believe the division has kept true to
the tom clancy name
and has decided to follow in the
direction that the man himself would
have taken
i strongly believe that the russians
will be playing out as the main
antagonist
now this isn't to say that the hunter
origins are 100 russian
but if not i still believe that they've
had a strong correlation in their
development
in some way and really from here the
biggest questions i have
coming out of all of this is what was
natalia and barton actually trying to do
in season three
what was their agenda what is it about
coney island
and what's still in play
after all that if you made it this far
although it's awesome to see the hunters
in the story
we really haven't learned too much about
their origins
in fact they've probably just gotten
more mysterious in some ways
we also need to remember that this was
just one hunter that we witnessed in the
season 3 manhunt
and his masks seemed quite different to
the ones we've seen previously
so it is possible that this hunter was
acting completely off mission from the
others
i really should point out that i am
aware of the leaks that were data mined
quite some time ago now but to be honest
i really haven't read into them too much
in fact i stopped skimming through them
before i even managed to get all the way
through season three
so none of this has been based on that
information and on that point
i ask that you respect others enjoyment
of the story and refrain from discussing
them in the comments
those that want to know the leaks should
have no problems in finding them
in saying that without spoiling the
first part of season 4 we are now able
to confirm that the black tusk
aren't restricting the recruitment to
the u.s military so this certainly opens
up new possibilities
like always this has all been based on
speculation around the small amount of
information we've been given
it's hard once you come up with an idea
not to go completely tunnel vision and
ignore any new information outside of
that one idea
but hopefully it's videos like this that
can expand your thoughts to other
possible solutions
to the mystery that we all love to hate
the hunters
if you have enjoyed this video of me
rambling about random division theories
that could honestly amount to absolutely
nothing
let me know i'm always skeptical about
making them as i'm generally a person
that's more based around hard facts
yet i still like to consider the
what-ifs
otherwise thank you very much for
watching i hope you've enjoyed it and
i'll catch you in the next one
cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]